ce matin un premier pas été franchi au
Sénat pour la réforme des retraites
de Sénat a adopté celles et ceux qui
sont attachés au système de répartition
et ça me paraît partition au système de
solidarité intergénérationnelle et à son
amélioration doivent se retrouver cet
après-midi et si votre taux s'il y a une
majorité à la semaine nationale faut-il
aller au vote sur cette réforme des
retraites où faut-il déclencher
l'article 49-3 surnommé par certains la
Grosse Bertha une adoption du texte sans
vote nous c'est à peu près 15 contre au
jour en ce moment et je vous dis encore
parmi les cinq autres il y a encore une
réflexion moi pour moi ça passe
[Applaudissements]
donc
merci mes chers collègues si le
gouvernement a une majorité évidemment
priorisée le vote sur le texte mais s'il
n'y a pas cette majorité je pense qu'il
vaut mieux encore le 49-3 plutôt que pas
du tout de réformes maintenant tout le
monde sait qu'on est à quelques voies
après et tout le monde sait qu'on joue
pas à la roulette russe pour employer
l'expression de bonnes de Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
la séance est suspendue pour deux
minutes j'ai été choqué scandalisé par
la transformation de l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale en une ZAD comme
la nupestre nous l'avait annoncé sur le
fondement
[Applaudissements]
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 et bah ce sera 49 3
oui écoutez ça prouve deux choses ça
prouve d'abord que il ne faut jamais
croire la parole d'Emmanuel Macron qui
est encore ce matin disait qu'il
souhaitait un vote
la force une réforme des retraites dont
personne ne veut et sur lequel avait de
faiblesse suprême ils sont obligés
d'utiliser le 49.3 est un signe qu'ils
enfoncent le pays tout entier dans une
crise de régime c'est le symbole d'un
président minoritaire dans le pays
minoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale qui
est obligé d'utiliser les traits les
plus autoritaires de la Constitution
pour imposer un texte que le pays ne
veut pas nous ne voulons pas dans ce
contexte rajoutez du chaos au cas où et
c'est pour cela que nous venons de
décider en réunion de groupe que nous
nous associerons à aucune motion de
censure c'est un texte qui n'a pas de
légitimité est un outil constitutionnel
Elisabeth borne a le droit de l'activer
pour faire passer sa réforme des retrait
de votre cours de constitutionnalité je
vous en disque non mais d'accord on a
compris oui vous trouvez ça très bien
vous avez raison
après avoir claironné partout qu'ils
avaient une majorité solide démontre en
même temps leur nullité leur amateurisme
et absence totale de respect attendez je
vais vous dire BFM a tout à fait le
droit
de me poser des questions
avec ce 49-3 nous avons été clairement
empêché de pouvoir voter nous députés
donc d'abord jusqu'au bout ce texte aura
été une manière de d'humilier de bafouer
le Parlement on a échangé autour du
président de la République avec les
ministres avec la majorité et on a
constaté que le compte n'y était pas
donc en accord avec le président de la
République j'ai engagé ma responsabilité
celle de mon gouvernement n'a pas su
convaincre d'abord sa propre majorité si
la recours aux 49-3 c'est d'abord parce
qu'ils ne font pas le plein de leur
majorité et s'ils n'ont pas convaincu
tout le monde non plus dans notre groupe
c'est je pense aussi au nom de ce défaut
de de méthode je le répète les
mobilisations et les grèves restent
d'actualité parce que notre objectif à
nous
c'est une seule chose qu'il compte
travaille pas deux ans de plus il faudra
pas s'étonner si le pays se déchire
quand on n'écoute pas ni le peuple et
quand on utilise des moyens quand on est
minoritaire pour essayer de faire passer
un texte qui est minoritaire au sein de
l'assemblée et bien ça se paye on va les
places de la Concorde vous voyez ici un
rassemblement spontané des dizaines
peut-être même plus de manifestants qui
sont place de la Concorde à Paris c'est
bon j'ai compris la Constitution tout ça
allez au revoir